so I don't really tend to do that many
update videos you know they get boring
after a while though this is what's
happening with me I don't really care
about what's happening with you but I'm
gonna tell you anyway I'm going to force
you to hear but I don't really want to
hear it but I'm going to tell you anyway
because I want you to know because it's
personal to me I don't do them because
it's always like you know do you really
care about them but i have actually some
important news for you some big news for
you that affects you as a viewer of my
channel of my reviews and it's pretty
exciting for me and i'd like to share
with you this is the very first year in
which i am going to travel to toronto
canada for the toronto international
film festival so that i can review a
whole bunch of awesome movies really
really early for you guys i'm gonna be
there for the premiere of a lot of
really awesome movies that i can't wait
to talk to you guys about I'm gonna let
you guys know what my schedule is so you
can know what movies I'm going to see on
which day now some people have asked me
Chris are you going to review these
movies all of them while you're there I
mean are you gonna be like in Toronto
like reviewing them there was no way I'd
be able to review like 15 to 20 movies
in the course of like 10 days that would
be awesome but it's just not going to
happen now let's talk about my schedule
so you guys can get an idea of what I'm
going to see and by any chance if you're
in Toronto and you're gonna be the film
festival come to one of these showing
and say hi to me it's cool man I'd love
to talk to you or girl whatever I'd
let's talk to you and you know talk to
you about movies whatever if you want to
say hi more than welcome to the festival
starts Thursday September 6 and right
off the bat is the premiere of looper at
six-thirty I am dying to see it I can't
wait to see it's actually my most
anticipated movie for the rest of this
year looper is more the ones I
definitely want to get a review up for
you as soon as possible even if i'm in
canada in some room somewhere in some
basement or something i'm going to be
doing a review of looper and trying to
get it to you as soon as possible and
then at eleven fifty-nine they're
showing dredd 3d yeah it looks pretty
horrible it really does but oddly enough
it currently has a one hundred percent
on rotten tomatoes that's odd to me then
on Friday the seventh this is the big
day for me this is I'm going to see like
four movies in one day it's the most I'm
going to be seeing in one day starting
right off with 1130am on the road with
kristen stewart and garrett hedlund then
it's 6 p.m. this is one of the biggest
ones for me the place beyond the pines
with Ryan Gosling this is from the
director of Blue Valentine super pumped
to see that movie i bet you it's going
to be really good that's a movie I want
to review as quick as possible that's
going to be a lot of excitement I've
heard
it whispered that mr. Gosling may be
there that would be cool then at 9pm
another really big one for me is the
master paul thomas anderson's next film
that's one of the ones I definitely want
to review for you guys as early as i can
and then at eleven fifty nine pm seven
psychopaths the new movie with Colin
Farrell Christopher Walken Sam Rockwell
Woody Harrelson moving on to Saturday
the eighth first we i'm going to be
seeing 11am is our go the new movie
directed by ben affleck and then at two
thirty p.m. movie that came out of
nowhere movie that I had no idea was
even existing in the world anywhere much
ado about nothing joss whedon's next
film that apparently he filmed for like
two weeks it's like his passion project
it just took him like a couple weeks to
do after he finished filming The
Avengers it stars Nathan Fillion where
is this coming from it doesn't have a
release date right now officially so I'm
excited to see this movie I'm kind of
curious about this one then it's 615 I'm
going to be seeing the perks of being a
wallflower with logan lerman Ezra Miller
and Emma Watson now moving on to Sunday
the 9th at 1130am I'm seeing Cloud Atlas
a new movie by the Wachowskis with Tom
Hanks Halle Berry all these people never
seen a trailer no footage nothing I have
not watched a thing for this movie I'm
going to go in completely fresh next
month I'm excited to see that movie you
guys may know that the matrix is one of
my favorite films of all time I adored
that movie I've watched me more times
than I can even count that's not really
true i guess i can count higher i just
don't know how many times i've seen it
that's what i meant to say and then it's
7pm the impossible with you and McGregor
and Naomi Watts is a true story about a
tsunami disaster and this this couple
that went through it together sunday is
my small day that's the day where I'm
hoping to be able to go out to dinner
with some people and just kind of
socialize a little bit more because up
until then I'm going to be like movie
movie movie nothing but movie now Monday
the 10th I'm going to be starting off to
30 p.m. with Arthur Newman a smoothie
with Colin Firth and emily blunt then
it's 7pm the new Terrence Malick movie
to the Wonder with Ben Affleck is going
to be there then at 10pm The Iceman
another film that I really know nothing
about and I'm trying to do that with
most of these movies is just not know
anything and just going completely fresh
my last day at tip is Tuesday the
eleventh and I'm seeing hyde park on
hudson at twelve-thirty with Bill Murray
and then the final film I'm seeing is
passion a film directed by brian de
palma starting new mere Epis and Rachel
McAdams what I can understand by the
pictures released it looks like it's
some sort of erotic
thriller of some kind with two women as
the leads so those in the movies that
I'm going to be seeing at TIFF hopefully
I can see all of them if you guys are
there if you're near bite if you're
coming say hi to me it's cool walk up to
me I don't care I want to talk to you
guys I want to meet you guys it's cool i
have a few other announcements I want to
make something really cool happen to me
today and I am just literally walking on
air I'm officially certified on rotten
tomatoes now my reviews count on rotten
tomatoes now if you guys watch my review
for the awakening then you saw at the
end I made an announcement that I've
started to write for our website called
movie Dexcom these are the reviews that
are being counted on rotten tomatoes and
I would love for you guys to maybe just
once a week go over there and see how
I'm doing with the reviews I post them
on facebook and like I said you gotta
like the Facebook page cuz the facebook
page is where you can find all this info
about me like hey I'm gonna be here hey
I'm gonna be here you want to come there
and maybe there or maybe a tip okay rule
but movie Dexcom is where I started
writing recently it's a great website
and I love writing for it and now that
I'm on Rotten Tomatoes it's like I don't
even know like I can't even when I see
my face there it's like is what is this
some dream some fantasy it's I love it
it's so great and I want to thank all of
you guys truly honestly honestly truly
thank you for sticking with me as I do
videos and for supporting me you guys
have helped me turn my hobby into
something more than a hobby and I really
appreciate that I'm not gonna change I'm
still just hey I'm Chris I'm in my room
you know I think nothing of myself
honestly I'm a guy who sits in his room
and talking about movies I mean it's
like what can i really say about myself
so thank you for being awesome that's
what i want to say if you want to like
me on facebook it's facebook.com / chris
stuckmann you can get a lot of this info
for me early you would have known about
tiff a long time ago my twitter handle
is chris underscore stuckmann that's
what you need to know for this info
please go over there and do that that
way I can get you guys this info and
stuff early and movie Dexcom that's why
I'm writing reviews for now I put the
link for the exact link that you need to
get to see all my reviews on movie decks
in the description of this video and you
can go along with me as i try to
rediscover this passion i used to have
for writing because i used to do that
that's how i started actually i want to
thank you guys want
again and as always if you like this
video then you can click right here and
get stuck my eyes